his weakness we have been told ad
nauseam by the mainstream media and by
the anti-trump right is that he's
reckless he's irresponsible he doesn't
know anything about government he
doesn't understand the complexity of our
trade relationship with China and what
we're seeing now is whether or that is
true or not that is what is bringing
China back to the negotiating table
because China was convinced that they
could pressure President Trump through
their entrance into the World Trade
Organization through their massive
economy through the massive hold that
they have over our manufacturing that
they could force Trump to blink and back
down especially as Trump faces a 2020
election year and he just won't do it we
can't know for sure whether Trump is
crazy or whether he's only pretending to
be crazy and you know I certainly think
he's only pretending to be crazy I think
he's a very sharp and capable guy but
the China wasn't willing to take that
bet and they came back to the
negotiating table this has been a
problem 19 years in the making 18 years
in the making since we let China into
the WTO and no president of either party
has wanted to deal with it
Trump has taken it on he's taken it on
during an election year which is quite
perilous for him and I think he's done
it with enough grit and enough performed
craziness that it just might work so he
calls President Trump himself calls what
what you call his performed craziness he
calls it whiplash negotiations he says
these are his trademarks this is his
quote he said it's the way I negotiate
it's done very well for me over the
years and it's doing even better for the
country do you want to know what I think
the kicker was I think the Chinese
expected this tit-for-tat tariff game
what I don't think the Chinese expected
I don't think the Chinese expected
President Trump to threaten to sever all
US commerce with China or to invoke that
law from 1977 the emergency economic
Powers Act and I think they were unsure
that he whether or not he would actually
do it because one of the things about
President Trump is when he makes a
threat he actually will follow through
on it even if the political class tells
him not to and the Chinese said oh wow
we didn't expect this we can't risk him
going through with it in order for a
negotiation to work
has to be able to make a credible threat
and China perceived the threat here to
be credible no other president could
have done this none of the other
candidates in 2016
none of Donald Trump's predecessors
except perhaps Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan was another one who was viewed as
a cowboy he was viewed as a little
dumber than his mark he was viewed as
crazy and he brought the Soviet Union to
the negotiating table ultimately he
brought the Soviet Union to collapse I
think we're seeing a similar style here
this is the advantage and well everyone
is busy criticizing President Trump for
all the tweets and talking about Mika
Brzezinski face and whatever I think now
we need to celebrate that that very same
quality that that unpredictability has
brought China finally to the negotiating
table after years and years of stealing
our property stealing our jobs not just
through the regular flow of trade but
stealing millions of jobs by illegally
devaluing their currency stealing our
secrets spying on us forcing us into
illegal taxes according to the WTO I
mean they have truly ripped us off for a
long time even Chuck Schumer and the
Democrats some of the Democrats in
minute Trump has managed to do what
other presidents have not managed to do
let's hope that he can finish the job